un chevreuse aux deux visages ce
dimanche 21 novembre à l'occasion de la
réception du leader aulnay dans le
championnat honneur les chevrotins avait
décidé de commencer fort en première
période une stratégie payante les locaux
arrivent à dérouler à prendre les
devants il mène 19 à 0 au bout de 20
minutes de jeu on fait notre plan de jeu
on est stable sur notre plan de jeu les
joueurs sont efficaces sur ce qu'on leur
demande donc on est devant logiquement
au score toute l'équipe était était
était bien
c'était bas que ce soit les avants
touche c'était très propre derrière
aussi donc pour moi c'était c'était un
mouvement d' équipe nous pas en face
c'est le mouvement des équipes surtout
sur les 20 premières minutes vingt
premières minutes de rêve qui laisse
place à 60 minutes de cauchemar
chevreuse recul au nez en profite pour
remonter au score et dépasser des shows
au teint qui ne marqueront plus score
final 26 à 19 pour les visiteurs le
bilan est très décevant puisque on mène
de 19 points à 20e minute et tout compte
fait on va pu marquer un seul point vos
remarques et 26 26 0 on prend non c'est
raide et globalement c'est très décevant
puisque on dont on fait vraiment quelque
chose de très très efficace au début et
ensuite on n'est pas capable d'être
constant et donc c'est très très
décevant chevreuse désormais 8e du
championnat devra se remobiliser
rapidement la prochaine journée est
programmée le 5 décembre sur le terrain
de vitry